in this video you're going to learn how
to solve quadratic equations using five
different methods we're going to go
through 11 problems I'm going to do 6
where I'm going to show you the
different techniques and then I'll have
five that you can practice on your own
at the end and we'll go through those as
well and you can kind of decide which is
going to be the best method to use in
each particular example so let's dive in
and talk about these five different
methods and how to apply them so the
first one we're going to talk about is
how to solve using this graphing method
so to do the graphing method you want to
get everything on one side of the equal
sign set it equal to zero and then what
we're going to do is we're going to
graph
this left side of the equation y equals
x squared plus 4X minus 5. now you
probably remember how to graph you're
going to want to find the vertex and we
can do that by using this formula
negative B over 2A or the opposite of B
over 2A so this is going to be a is one
B is 4 and C is negative 5. so the
opposite of B is going to be negative 4
over 2 times a which is 1. so negative 4
over 2 is negative 2. so what that tells
us is that at negative 2
that's our axis of symmetry that's the
line that divides the parabola in half
but if we take the negative 2 and we put
it back in for x
we can solve
for the y coordinate of the vertex so
that comes out to 4 minus 8 minus five
so that's a negative 4 minus 5 which is
negative 9. so you can see here that our
vertex is going to be at a negative two
negative 9. so let's plot that one two
three four five six seven eight nine
right there is our vertex now what I
would do is I'd make a table and I'd
pick some points on either side
of the vertex since it's symmetric so
negative 4 and 0 negative five and one
now let's go ahead and put some of these
values in so if we put negative 1 in
let's see so negative 1 would be one
plus negative 4 which is negative 3
minus 5 is negative 8. so if we know
this is negative eight negative three is
also negative 8 since it's the same on
both sides so that's going to put us
here
and here if we put 0 in that's going to
give us 0 plus 0 minus 5 which is
negative five so these are both going to
be negative five so two three four
negative 5.
right about here and then if we put
let's say 1 in that's going to give us 1
plus 4 is 5 minus 5 is 0. so that means
that both of these are going to be zero
so at one we're at zero and over here at
uh negative 5 we're at zero so if we
graph this
there's our Parabola and we're
interested in where the parabola is
equal to zero where the Y value is equal
to zero those are the X intercepts or
the zeros and you can see that occurs at
a negative five
and at one so those are going to be your
Solutions now the only time that I would
really use this graphing method is if
they said solve this equation and here's
the graph then all you have to do is
look at the graph and say oh it's
crossing the x-axis at negative five and
one those are my Solutions okay but I
wouldn't take all the time to graph it
because it's time consuming as well as
the fact that it doesn't always cross at
integer values so you might like if it
crosses somewhere in between these two
values it would be kind of hard to
estimate or you know find that exact
answer you just be estimating so
graphing methods not my favorite unless
the graph is given let's take a look at
some of the other examples okay for
example number two now let's talk about
the factoring method now the factoring
method I generally use when it's easy to
factor and that usually occurs when the
a value this coefficient in front of the
x squared term is just equal to one then
all you have to do is say can I find two
numbers that multiply to C
but add to B and then if you can find
that that's going to be factored easily
so you can say hmm in this case what two
numbers multiply to 15 but add to
negative 8.
well in this case you can see that's
going to be negative 5 times negative 3
is 15 and negative 5 plus negative 3 is
negative 8 and we can go right into our
factored form then once we have it
factored we just have to set each factor
each group equal to zero and solve
so here if I add 5 to both sides X is
equal to 5. if I add 3 to both sides X
is equal to 3 and those are our
Solutions so again factoring is when
it's easy to factor usually when the a
is equal to 1. now for number three and
four
let's talk about the square root method
so you use the square root method when
you have a perfect square now like in
this first example you can see oh we
just have an x squared term but no x to
the first term so you can get this by
itself and take the square root of both
sides that's the square root method same
thing here you have a binomial squared
that's a perfect square we just have to
get that by itself and take the square
root of both sides so let's look at
these examples here now for number three
I'm trying to get this x squared by
itself so instead of multiplying by 5 4
let me multiply by the reciprocal
four-fifths
to both sides of the equation this way
these cancel or undo each other and
we're left with x squared
and here 75 is like 75 over 1. so we can
do a little bit of cross reducing 5 goes
in here once 5 goes in here 15 times 15
times 4 is 60 divided by 1 is 60. now
all I have to do is take the square root
of both sides remember when you take the
square root of both sides you get two
answers plus or minus positive or
negative and then square root of 60 we
can write that as 4 times 15. the reason
I did that is because 4 is a perfect
square that's just going to be 2. 15 is
not a perfect square and we can't pull
out or divide out any perfect squares
from 15. so this would be like an exact
answer plus or minus 2 square root of
15.
now you could also do this on the
calculator and get a decimal
approximation but that depends on what
your teacher is looking for now for
number four see this one we have this
binomial squared so we're just going to
take the square root of both sides like
that the square and the square root
cancel square root of 16 is going to be
plus or minus 4. now in this particular
problem sometimes it's good to split
this up into two equations what I mean
is you could write one where it's equal
to positive 4 and 1 where it's equal to
negative 4 and then solve them
separately so if I subtract 3 from both
sides
you can see we get X is equal to one or
X is equal to negative seven
and those would be your two solutions
for this problem let's take a look at
another example okay for number five now
let's talk about this completing the
square method now I use the completing
the square method when the a value this
coefficient in front of x squared is
equal to one but the B value the number
in front of the x is an even number like
2 4 6 8 like that that's going to be
when it's easiest to use completing the
square now if the a value is not one you
could let's say it was two you could
divide everything by two or if it was
three you could divide everything by
three but if you get fractions that
might not be your best bet because it's
going to be a little bit more
challenging to use the completing the
square method
so in this case to complete the square
what you want to do is you want to get
the constant to the other side so I'm
just going to subtract 2 from both sides
just to get that constant kind of out of
the way
then to complete the square you take
half of the B value and you square it so
you sometimes I do this work off to the
side I say negative 10 divided by 2 and
I Square it so that's negative 5
negative 5 squared is 25. if you add 25
to the left side of the equation you
have to add it to the right to keep it
balanced
now what we can do is we can Factor this
left side and it's going to be a perfect
square like a binomial squared it's
always going to be half of this B value
so x minus 5 the quantity squared you
can check your work by writing x minus 5
times x minus 5 and foiling you'll get
back to the original
if this is plus 10x this would be plus
5.
and that equals 23 and then now all we
have to do is use what we did when we
did the square root method because this
is a perfect square you can just take
the square root of both sides so that's
going to give us plus or minus the
square root of 23
x minus 5. now what you can do here to
get X by itself is add 5 but make sure
you add the 5 in front of or to the left
of the plus or minus sign so this is
going to be X is equal to 5 plus or
minus the square root of 23 and that's
an exact answer now you could do this on
your calculator 5 plus square root of 23
get a decimal approximation 5 minus the
square root of 23 get a decimal
approximation but this is exact so again
completing the square method I would
only tend to use this if a is equal to 1
and the B is an even number okay now
number six this is kind of like a
catch-all one the quadratic formula and
you can use this in any scenario it
doesn't matter what a b c are whether
they're even or a is not 1 or a is one
it basically when I use a quadratic
formula it's like it's going to be
difficult to factor I don't have a graph
I don't have perfect squares you know a
is not equal to 1 or B is is not an even
num number it's difficult to factor
basically when it's a real kind of a
mess so to speak that's when I would use
a quadratic formula that's going to be
your best bet but you can use it in any
one of the and basically at any point or
any time you can use a quadratic formula
so in this case a is 3 B is negative 2 C
is negative 4. make sure you capture
whether it's positive or negative and
then you're going to want to memorize
that quadratic formula there so let's go
ahead and do it we've got X is equal to
the opposite of B so the opposite of
negative 2 is positive 2. pulse or mine
is a b squared so negative 2 squared is
4 minus 4 times a which is 3 times C
which is negative four
all divided by 2 times a 2 times 3 is 6.
okay so let's simplify a little bit here
and this sometimes students make little
mistakes with these signs so be careful
you've got a negative 4 times 3 is
negative 12. negative 12 times negative
4 is positive 48 so we have 4 plus 48
which is 52. so this is X is equal to 2
plus or minus the square root of 52 all
over 6. now square root of 52 we can
simplify
into 4 times 13
and the reason I did that is because 4
is a perfect square so the square root
of 4 is just going to be 2
and then what you can do you can reduce
all these numbers by two sometimes
students will just do maybe this one or
this one but you want to make sure you
divide everything by the same number to
reduce it you could also factor out a 2
and then reduce that like that but I'm
just going to divide everything by 2. so
that's going to be 1 plus or minus 1
square root of 13 all divided by 3 and
that's an exact answer using our
quadratic formula now what we're going
to do next is I'm going to give you five
examples and I'd like for you to try to
practice these on your own go ahead and
pause the video and decide which method
you should use
in each one in each case now you might
be able to use more than one but just
pick one I would try to pick whatever is
going to be the easiest method and just
so you know I kind of mixed them up I
didn't put them in this particular order
okay so go ahead and pause the video
what do you think you would do on number
seven and number eight and number nine
well let's see so for number seven when
I look at this I can see that the a
value is one
and is this easy to factor are there two
numbers that multiply to the C value but
add to the B value yes there are looks
like I could multiply negative four
and positive 3 together that gives you
negative 12 and negative 4 plus 3 is
negative 1. so that we can go right into
the factored form and once we have it
factored we can set both factors
equal to zero and solve so if I subtract
3 from both sides we get x equals
negative 3 and if I add 4 to both sides
we get x equals 4 and those are our
Solutions so this one was easily
factored so factoring method is real
quick and easy
for number eight what did you do on this
one
well this one you can see the a value is
1.
but there's not a number that multiply
two numbers that multiply to C but add
to B so this one's not easily factored
but what I do notice is that this B
value is even
so this is going to be good for
completing the square so let's go ahead
and do the completing the square method
by subtracting 1 to the other side just
to get it out of the way then we take
half of this B value
and square it so half of 8 is 4 and 4
squared is 16 so we're going to add 16
to both sides of the equation
so that gives us 15
and then we can Factor this this is now
a perfect square it's going to be X plus
4 the quantity squared remember it's
always half of that b value if this was
minus 8x that'd be minus 4. now we can
basically use our square root method
because this is a perfect square and
we're going to take the square root of
both sides so we get plus or minus the
square root of 15. here the square and
the square root cancel so we get X plus
4 and then if I subtract 4 from both
sides
we get negative 4 plus or minus the
square root of 15. When You Subtract
that 4 make sure you put it to the left
or in front of that plus or minus sign
so this was a good method for completing
this Square now for number nine what do
you think about this one 4x squared is
equal to 9.
well this one you can see we've got a
perfect square here we've got x squared
so I would use the square root method by
dividing both sides by four
and then what we can do is we can take
the square root of both sides to get X
by itself remember when you take the
square root of both sides you get two
answers plus or minus the square root of
9 is 3 the square root of 4 is 2 so we
get plus or minus 3 over 2. let's take a
look at two more examples see if you can
do number 10 and number 11. so for
number 10 we've got 2x squared minus 3x
minus 5 equals zero what do you think
would be the best method to use in this
case
well it looks like there's a lot going
on here the a is not one the B is not
even
and it looks like this might be a little
bit tricky to factor so I'm just going
to go straight to the quadratic formula
so here you can see a is 2 B is negative
3 and C is negative 5. so plugging those
values into our quadratic formula the
opposite of B would be positive three
plus or minus B squared negative 3
squared is 9 minus 4 times a which is 2
times C which is negative five all
divided by 2 times a 2 times 2 is 4.
so if we simplify here let's see what we
have negative 4 times 2 is negative 8
negative 8 times negative 5 is 40. 9
plus 40 is 49
and we know the square root of 49 is 7.
so we can see 3 plus 7 is 10 divided by
four
and three minus 7 is negative 4 divided
by 4. so this reduces to 5 over 2
or negative one so those are your two
solutions using the quadratic formula
this one you could actually Factor but
it was a little bit more challenging to
factor number 11 this one we're not even
given an equation but we are given in a
graph so obviously we want to use the
graphing method and we can see that
where is it equal to zero it's where it
crosses the x-axis and that's going to
be right here at negative 1 and positive
3. and so those would be the solutions
or your zeros or your x-intercepts so
great job if you're able to follow all
the different examples in this video if
you want more practice and you want to
see more explanations and more problems
follow me over to a previous video I did
on the same topic talking about solving
quadratic equations using five different
methods and I'll see over in that video